jetzt aber zum wichtigen teil ich gebe
das ergebnis
bekannt mitgliederzahl
736 abgegebene stimmen
ungültige stimmzettel 3
mit ja haben gestimmt
395 abgeordnete
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielen dank wir können das gleich
weitermachen aber ich wollte noch das
andere die anderen stimmt zahlen bekannt
geben mit nein haben gestimmt
363 erforderliche mehrheit von
mindestens
369 stimmen erreicht er ist gemäß
artikel 63 absatz 2 des grundgesetzes
zum bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt kommt aber die alles entscheidende
frage ich frage sie herr abgeordneter
scholz nehmen sie die wahl an
das war laut und vernehmlich herr
bundeskanzler
ich gratuliere ihm den namen des ganzen
hauses zu ihrer wahl auch persönlich
wünsche ich ihnen viel kraft für die vor
ihnen liegenden aufgaben und das
ergebnis der wahl werde ich jetzt
unverzüglich dem herrn bundespräsidenten
mitteilen und voraussichtlich um 12 uhr
findet die eidesleistung des
bundeskanzlers statt der wieder beginn
der sitzung wird auch rechtzeitig durch
klingeln signal angekündigt und jetzt
unterbreche ich die sitzung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also dass der blumen moment olaf scholz
ist bundeskanzler der
republik deutschland erst gerade gewählt
worden mit
395 stimmen seiner ampel koalition das
ist deutlich weniger als die ampel
stimmen hat es waren heute auch
zahlreiche bundestagsabgeordnete
nicht im plenum haben an dieser wahl
nicht teilgenommen aber